we've already learned that cellular
respiration can be broken down into
roughly three phases cellular
respiration
broke down into three phases the first
is glycolysis
glycolysis which literally means the
breaking down of glucose
breaking
down
of glucose and then this this can occur
with or without oxygen if we don't have
oxygen then we go over to fermentation
we'll talk that about that in the future
go over to fermentation and in humans it
produces lactic acid in in other types
of organisms it might produce alcohol or
ethanol but if we have oxygen and for
the most part we're going to assume that
we can proceed forward with oxygen if
there is oxygen then we could proceed
forward to the krebs cycle
krebs cycle sometimes called the citric
acid cycle because it
deals with citric acid the same thing
that's in orange juice or lemons and
then from there we proceed to the
electron transport chain
electron
transport chain and we learned in the
first overview video of cellular
respiration that this is where the bulk
of the atp is actually produced although
it uses raw materials that came out of
these phases up here now what i want to
do in this video is just focus on
glycolysis
just focus on glycolysis and this is
kind of a you know it's it's sometimes a
challenging task because you can really
get stuck in the weeds and i'll show you
the weeds in a little bit in the actual
mechanism and it can be very daunting
but what i want to do is simplify it for
you so you can kind of have the big
takeaways and then we can appreciate and
then maybe when we look at the the weeds
of glycolysis we can we can make a
little bit more sense of it so
glycolysis or really cellular
respiration it starts off with glucose
it starts off with glucose and glucose
we know it's formula it's c6h12o6
and you know i could draw its whole
structure would take a little time but
i'm just going to focus on the carbon
backbone so we could you know it could
it is a ring or it can be a ring but i'm
just going to draw it as six
carbons
six carbons in a row now there's two
kind of important phases of glycolysis
that are good to know one i call the
investment phase
and the investment stage pays actually
uses two atps
so use
two
it actually uses two atp so you know the
whole purpose of cellular respiration
works to generate atp's but right from
the get-go i actually have to use two
atps but i use two atps and i'm then i'm
going to essentially break up the
glucose
into
two
three carbon
into two three carbon
compounds right here that actually also
have a phosphate group on them
the phosphate groups are coming from
those atps they also have a phosphate
group on them this is often called well
there's a lot of names for it out you
know sometimes called p gal you really
don't have to know this or
phospho
phosphoglycer
glyceraldehyde really challenging my
spelling skills right here that's not
that important to know all you have to
know is in this first phase you use two
atps that's why i call it the investment
phase if we use a business analogy
investment
phase
and then each of these two pgal
molecules can then go into the payoff
phase so in the payoff phase
in the payoff phase each of these pgals
turn into pyruvate
which is another three carbon and but
it's reconfigured but the process of it
going to pyruvate and let me write
pyruvate
in blue because this is something that's
at least it's good to know the word and
i'll show you structure in a second
pyruvate sometimes it's called pyruvic
acid
same thing
pyruvic acid and that's essentially the
end product of glycolysis so you start
off with glucose in the investment phase
you end up in this phosphoglyceraldehyde
which essentially you broke up your
glucose and you put a phosphate on
either end of it and then those each
independently go through the payoff
phase so you end up with two molecules
of pyruvate for every molecule of
glucose you started off with now you're
saying hey so it was a payoff phase what
did what was our payoff
well our payoff we got
for each of for from this let me write
this down as a payoff phase this is our
payoff
phase and i apologize for the white
background i did it because the
mechanism i'm showing you i copy and
pasted it from wikipedia and they had a
white background so i just ran with the
white background for this video but i
personally at least like the back black
background a lot better but this is the
payoff
phase right here and so when we go from
the
phosphoglyceraldehyde to the pyruvate or
the pyruvic acid we produce two things
or i guess we could say we could produce
three things we produce
each of these each of these p gals to
pyruvates produce two atps
two atps so i'm gonna produce two atps
there i'm gonna produce two atps
there and then they each produce an nadh
n
a
d h may i do it in a darker color
d h and of course they're not producing
you know they're not producing the whole
molecule in a vacuum essentially what
they're doing is they
they're starting with the raw material
of an nad plus
so they start off with an nad plus
and they essentially they essentially
reduce it by adding a hydrogen remember
we learned a couple of videos ago that
you can view reduction as a gain in
hydrogen so the nad gets reduced to nadh
and then later on these nadhs are used
in the electron transport chain to
actually produce atps
so the big takeaway here if i were to
kind of write the the reaction that we
get for
for glycolysis is that you start off
with glucose
you start off with glucose
and
you need some nad plus
and a
d plus and actually for every mole of
glucose you're going to need two
nad pluses you're going to need
two atps
you're going to need two atp so i'm just
writing all the ingredients that we need
to start off with and then you're going
to need well let me say well these guys
are going to be adp's before we turn
them to adp so i'll write plus four
a d p's and then
after performing glycolysis
glycolysis and let me write it here let
me write also a sorry that was an ad
a d
p's
let me just rewrite that part right
there
four adps and then you maybe need two
phosphate groups because we're uh or
we're gonna need four phosphate groups
plus four
i'll just call them sometimes they're
right written like that but maybe i'll
write it like this four phosphate groups
i'll do four
phosphate groups like that and then once
you perform glycolysis
once you perform glycolysis you have two
pyruvates
two pyruvates you have two
nadhs nadhs
the nad has been reduced it gained a
hydrogen rig oil rig reduction is gain
an electron but in the biological sense
we think of a gaining the hydrogen
because hydrogen is very
non-electronegative so you're hogging
its electrons you gained its electrons
so two nadhs and then
plus these two adp atps get used in the
investment phase that's why i kind of
wrote them a little separately so these
two get used so then you're left with
two
a
d
p's
and then these guys essentially get
turned into atp so plus four
a
t p's i guess we didn't need four we
only needed a net of two phosphate
groups because two jump off of here and
then we need a total of two more to get
four jumping on there
but the big picture is you start with
glucose you end up with two pyruvates
you use up two atps you get four atps so
you have a net of two atps formed let me
write that very big
net
what you get out of glycolysis is two
atps
you get
two
nadhs
that can each later be used the electron
transport chain to produce three atps
but you get two nadhs and you get two
pyruvates which are going to be
re-engineered into
acetyl coas that are going to be the raw
materials for the krebs cycle but these
are the outputs
these right here are the outputs of
glycolysis so now that we have that big
picture let's actually look at the
mechanism because this is a little bit
more daunting when you see it here but
we'll see the same themes that i just
talked about we're starting with the
glucose
right there it is a six
chain it's in a circle it's in a ring
one two three four five six carbons i
could write it like that just to make it
a huge over simplification goes through
a few steps i use an atp here so that's
let me do that in a color we do it in
orange whenever i use an atp i use one
atp there i use one atp there and just
like i told you
they have a slightly different name for
it but this is the
phosphoglyceraldehyde right here they
call it glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate it's
the exact same molecule
but as you can see just you know when i
drew it very roughly before you've got
one two three carbons there
one two
three carbons there and it also has a
phosphate group on it the phosphate
group is actually attached to the oxygen
but for just for simplification i draw
the phosphate group just like that and
we draw we i showed that right here this
was the phosphoglyceraldehyde right here
this is the actual structure up here but
i think you know sometimes we look at
the structure you it's it's easy to miss
the big picture and there are two of
these they kind of say that you know you
can go back and forth with this uh with
this other kind of isomer of this but
the important thing is you have two of
these compounds that are now three
carbon compounds glucose has been split
and now we're
ready to enter the payoff phase and
remember you have two of these compounds
two of these compounds right here that's
why when they drew this mechanism they
wrote times two right there because the
glucose has been split into two of these
molecules so each of the molecules are
now going to do this right here and for
each of the glyceraldehyde three
phosphates or p gals or
phosphoglyceraldehydes we can look at
the mechanism we can look at the
mechanism say okay look here there's
going to be an adp turning into an atp
there so this is plus one atp and then
we see it
again happening here on our way to
pyruvate
on our way to pyruvate right there then
we have another plus
one atp so for each of the p gals or the
phosphoglyceraldehydes that were
produced the phosphoglyceraldehydes that
would produce we're producing two atps
in the payoff phase now there were two
of these so total for one glucose we're
going to produce four atps in the payoff
phase so the payoff phase four atps in
the investment phase we used one two
atps so total net atp's directly
generated from glycolysis is two atps
right four
gross produced but we had to invest two
in the investment phase and then the
nads and the nadhs we see right here
for each
phosphoglyceraldehyde or glyceraldehyde
3-phosphates or p-gals or whatever you
want to call them at this stage right
here
you see that we are reducing nad plus to
nadh
so this this happens once for each of
these compounds and obviously there are
two of these glucose got split into two
of these guys so two nadhs
two nadhs are going to be produced and
later these are going to be using the
electron transport chain to to actually
each produce
three atps
and then finally when everything is said
and done we're left with the pyruvates
and it's nice at least that they made it
nice and big we can take a look at what
a pyruvate looks like and just as
promised you know we can look at all the
oxygen bonds and all of that but it is a
three carbon
structure has a three carbon background
bone so the the end result is that that
carbon that the glucose got split in
half it got oxidized some of the
hydrogens got stripped off of it as you
can see there's only three hydrogens
here we started off with 12 hydrogens in
glucose and now it has it's it's it's
carbon is bonding more strongly with
oxygen so it's essentially having its
electrons stolen by the oxygens or
hogged by the oxygens so carbon has
gotten oxidized in this process there's
going to be more oxidation left to do
and in the process we were able to
generate two
net atps
to net atps and two
nadhs that can later be used to produce
atps anyway hopefully you found that
helpful